so let's go straight to our first guest
fiona hill now a senior fellow at the
brookings institution and an expert on
russia she was an adviser to three men
who held the most powerful office in the
world but as a woman from the north of
england she came up against challenges
and has a remarkable insight into how
one president donald trump dealt with
world leaders and women in power
fiona thanks so much for coming on the
show i've been looking forward to
meeting you so i'm really glad you're
here and i wanted to kick off with where
you came from let's start with who you
are
um you're a working-class girl from the
northeast and you ended up advising
three presidents on foreign policy
to those who don't know you can you join
the dots in a way that makes sense to
people about where you started and where
you got to
yeah look um it was very much the
product of um
time and place um as you mentioned uh
working class but i grew up in the north
of england in county durham small town
bishop auckland at a time when basically
the bottom had totally fallen out of the
local economy
um it was born in 1965
um at that time the local coal mines are
closing down my dad had been a coal
miner the only job he'd been able to
find when all the mines had closed down
was in the local hospital and the
national health service and uh bishop
parks is a porter you know beginning on
really the lowest of the economic ranger
and having to sort of reinvent himself
and when i was leaving school in 1984
not only were all the mines it was all
you know british
nationalized industry british rail
british coal british steel british
shipbuilding the national health service
i mean pretty much everybody i knew
worked in the nationalized sectors and
not in the private sector
unemployment in the town was really high
but unemployment for youth across the
entire country was very high only 90 um
well i just said 90 of kids leaving
school in 1984 didn't immediately have
something to go on to
i was very lucky i was in that five or
six percent of kids who had the ability
to go to college or polytechnic
university um you know doing my a levels
and the local education authority in
this case county durham because of the
basis of means testing and if i'd done
well enough would pay for me the chance
to go to college and my dad basically
said to me at the time look pet you know
there's nothing for you here yeah if you
get a chance to go to
university and you get a chance to
education that he hadn't got he left
school at 14 you've got to take it but
really
the the reason i was able to take that
opportunity was because my local
education authority paid for all the
fees and a maintenance grant for me to
go to university and that kind of
ability to do that now has really
reduced i mean it was again time and
place placed my dad pushing me out to go
somewhere else and to do something else
because there wasn't any jobs in bishop
auckland at the time but the ability
because of local
education authority educational grants
and then i was able after that to get a
scholarship to go to harvard university
in 1989 again because of money not that
was given by the government but that
money here that had been endowed to
harvard university by you know a
benefactor it was actually frank knox
the former secretary for the us with the
navy in world war ii we'd given money
for the british commonwealth and i got
that grant to go to harvard so all the
way along the reason i'm where i am
today is because there was a grant to
subsidy a fellowship
in a scholarship uh some kind of
assistance i mean i i couldn't have done
this on my own without that now you uh
went on to advise three u.s presidents
you are an expert on russia you have uh
written a book on putin you've obviously
just written another book
donald trump
you advised donald trump um
when did you realize it wasn't going to
work out between you
and donald trump was it sudden or was it
this gradual realization that i'm not
going to be able to do business with
this guy he's just not it was right from
the very beginning i mean when people
say you advise trump i didn't advise him
on anything in fact very few people did
because he didn't really listen to
advice and he just wasn't particularly
interested and he had a kind of a vision
of who should be an advisor anywhere and
it certainly wasn't you know kind of
middle-aged woman with a funny accent
and right from the very beginning it was
basically who were you
what could you possibly know about you
know any of this
were there any sort of women you'd think
he would take advice from or was it just
anti-women no it wasn't anti-women i
mean there were women that he um trusted
and worked with for a long time and
somebody like you know people be
familiar with kellyanne conway do you
think he had quite a bit of respect for
her being his own daughter ivanka trump
i mean the times when he clearly
listened to her you know there were
there were others who were in his orbit
you know we hear about hope hicks you
know for example who was one of his
assistants
so it wasn't just that was just you know
that trust and you know who they were
you know i've actually saw him interact
with people like angela merkel
chancellor of germany and listening to
her she explained a lot of things to him
in various meetings he took us seriously
because he was a chancellor of germany
it was kind of who you were and how you
were related to him
take through seriously because i
remember watching how he treated her
because i saw prescott and i i thought
he
was not always respectful to her
no look i think you know this is a bit
of a bizarre thing
to say she would have been better off if
she spoke another language other than
english trump you know responds to
people i was going to use publishing as
an example right he had to listen to him
people go oh my god he was always
talking to putin for great length
because he could be translated
and so part of the whole power of people
like putin or even you know angela
merkel you know if she's decided to
speak in german was that trump had to
actually listen because he didn't know
the language and he couldn't interrupt
him
and he couldn't kind of hone in on
something they said because he had to
hear them out where was with theresa may
i mean he immediately could just
interrupt her and you know he often did
that with other people as well if they
had an accent i mean you know for
example macron of france if he spoke in
english rather than in french
and you know he was stumbling for a word
or he didn't use quite the right word
trump would hone in and immediately
interrupt them
okay because that was kind of his style
and also if your voice was of a higher
register as theresa may's could be i
mean i'm
cognizant of that myself i mean i don't
speak in a particularly low register
trump would immediately see that as a
kind of sign of weakness
and it was also people's electoral
status so after theresa may for example
called the snap election and her
majority was reduced he saw that as a
weakness it was kind of reflection of
his own fears of you know having a
reduced majority and how that made
people think about you his epitome of
the strong powerful leader was a guy
spoke in a big deep voice
and who you know kind of basically in
his view then come under detention did
you ever did you ever see him interrupt
with theresa may i did and many other
people as well i had the whole of europe
in my portfolio not just uh russians
didn't make you angry did you find it
angry when you thought she was the prime
very irritating because he did that with
other people as well i mean as i said he
would interrupt people he would jump in
on them
um he wouldn't you know listen to them
you know with respect there was not just
that mutual respect with people
and about you i read in an interview
actually i also read it it's in your
book
uh that you said that his
you were referred to by his chief of
staff
as i hope you don't mind me repeating
this as the as the russia [ __ ] yeah i
don't that after the fact actually it
was a journalist who was um writing a
kind of a profile of me uh for one of
the american magazines and who
interviewed a lot of people around that
and he said did you know they called you
that and i was like no but i wasn't
particularly surprised this wasn't you
know across the board this was the kind
of coterie of people around around trump
his chief of staff yeah and it was
basically who does she think she is you
know she thinks she knows all of this
stuff but you don't know all that stuff
but it's that it's not it's not
repudiation i mean look you know as a
woman i mean you and i and many women in
public life and many women not in public
life have to basically put up with that
kind of dismissiveness well actually now
you've said it i i wanted to ask you
about something i hate you across it
because obviously you live in the u.s
but
um
there has been an issue done i think
we've got the newspaper article where by
angela rainer who is the
deputy
labour leader uh has had a
rather well very misogynistic article
directed there you can see there's stone
the crows tories accuse rayner of basic
instinct ploy to distract
boris you can see angerena there and
they're liking it to sharon stone there
in in basic incident likening her to the
deputy leader of the labour party
there's a quote in that piece
uh of angie raynier where this is a an
anonymous conservative mp saying she
knows she can't compete with boris's
oxford union debate in training but she
has other skills which he lacks angie
left school at 16
from a working class background had a
baby is now extremely successful
politician
what what do you think about
that about
that quote about that article i think
it's just a classic misogynistic put
down i mean quite recently after i've
been speaking out you know donald trump
said about me she'd be nothing without
that accent which of course is ironic
because in a uk context you know the
accent
marks me as being working class from the
north of england would get other kinds
of comments you know in the uk
you know obviously one view of an
accident in the u.s another but it's
just that kind of put down like you just
said about the the russia [ __ ] when
people
feel intimidated by women in powerful
positions which is clearly the case with
angela reyna i'm not wanting to be
offensive to reach the daily mail but
you know that always you know i'm not
surprised that there's this kind of
commentary that people don't check
themselves when they're writing you know
these kinds of things
and absolutely just what you said it's
indicative of the problem that women
have over and over again in public life
doesn't matter what kind of background
that they have but especially people
from the working class i'm also told by
people oh well look you know there's
lots of people like you who've risen up
in the time you know since you have
that's just not true
and you know i mean show me the number
of working-class women you know with a
northern accent or any kind of accent
that would mark them there who are in
public life and then case in point
angela reign as you said really a
remarkable unbelievably remarkable
career and personal trajectory they said
leaving school after 16 having to raise
you know a child on her own i mean i i
saw in that picture she's not wearing
anything different from maya
i mean what are women supposed to wear
what what are we you know telling people
and there's an element you know in my
book that i talk about right from the
very beginning when i had to give
evidence an impeachment trial
the first thing
that i was told was we'll have to figure
out what you're going to wear and i was
like not what i'm going to say i'm in
preparation if i'm going to answer the
questions but about what you're going to
wear so you're not distracting yeah so
that people won't look at you and say oh
god look at that woman
i know that feeling um
just before i want to get on to russia
and ukraine because you're an expert and
i really want i've got so many questions
to ask you one thing about
trump the impeachment child you became a
national uh figure you are now very well
known in the us and you were
highly praised for how you handled uh
that
testimony that you had to give but in
the book two you write
about how a lot of friends and
associates had warned you against
working at the weiss house under trump
do you regret not heeding those warnings
was it mistakes go and try to work for
him no i don't think it was a mistake at
all because i did it in the spirit of
public service you know patriotism for
the united states at a time when the
russians and putin had messed around in
u.s politics and it create an absolute
chaos on the domestic front that we're
still dealing with now
and you know i'd written a whole book
with a colleague about putin i'd been in
the national intelligence council so
i've been an intel analyst it wasn't
that i didn't know what putin was up to
i think where i should have been more
careful when i went in because i didn't
pay attention to what they said and i
took it very seriously i wanted to make
sure i didn't get you know kind of
embroiled in the domestic politics was
really doing my homework about some of
the other people who were there
because i knew more about the kremlin
and also dirty politics and i really did
about how this political machine was
working around trump this personal
coterie the personalization of
everything
on our trip to india last week with the
prime minister he said he became the
first g7 leader to explicitly say he
thinks putin will win this war could win
this war
he's right isn't he he he is going to
win but you you would say he has to me
any cost what does that look like well
it doesn't look good for him either i
mean you know when we say win define a
win right there's a public victory in
other words when you know things are
devastating result of it and we could
very easily seeing putin himself
prevailing by still being in office in
the same way that bashar al-assad has
done it in syria complete devastation in
the country but he's still there that is
exactly but putin that would be a win it
wouldn't be a win for anybody else by
their definition and not for the russian
people either or for russian oligarchs
or for you know kind of the russian
military that would not be a win but for
putin it will be because he has
prevailed and his act of will has been
borne out and yes he um has uh
devastated the russian economy but in
his view we'll already have devastated
ukraine and shown us who's the boss you
understand his mind probably better than
a lot of people what does it look what's
the on the ground
result for him that makes him claim
victory or allows him to claim victory
or gives him an off-ramp right so he can
end the war yeah he wants us to take an
off-ramp and ukrainians to sue for
surrender so
ending the war would be declaring
victory
and it might look something along the
lines of what he said to george w bush
in 2008
which is you know george ukraine isn't a
real country part of it is in eastern
europe and part of it was given to us or
part of it belongs to us
and you can just imagine him being in
possession of the whole of the donbass
donatson lukansk the rubble of mario
paul and all the cities around the sea
of azov all the northern parts of crimea
linking all of that together crimea to
eastern ukraine having odessa and the
other fabled black sea ports of ukraine
in jeopardy as well and ukraine
effectively cut off from the black sea
and dismembered
and that looks like a win to putin how
does it end for him i mean i interviewed
chris still the other day and he said he
didn't see a way back like he
that he can't
lead russia after this all ends in a way
i mean what how does it end for putin a
palace coup he died i mean how he
prevails and he just grinds it out over
another decade with russia
the pariah of the world or the west at
least yeah all of those things because
you know i mentioned bashar al-assad we
said assad should be gone in what was it
2012 10 years on he's still there
robert mugabe we kind of felt there's no
way that he could keep on going in
zimbabwe so much you know push back
against him he just goes and dies in his
position we still got nicholas maduro in
venezuela we've got you know that we had
the castros one after another in cuba
you know every time people said oh
surely this must be the end i mean i
think it's exactly that it could be a
combination of all of those things and
but it also could be
you know there could be a change i mean
we've often been caught out before right
nobody expected gorbachev to come along
and even under medvedev when putin
stepped back and put dmitry medvedev
into the presidency for a while there
was a bit of a change of pace as well as
a change of face
you know we don't have crystal balls
something unexpected can always happen
but you don't think that there is an
internal
there's a eternal rebellion against him
that there aren't people around him that
will think this has gone too far you
don't think there's an internal coup
scenario really it's possible we saw
that with gorbachev right when gorbachev
um was pushing through you know kind of
reforms and there was a push back by
hardliners it's entirely possible that
but again i can't say in what kind of
time frame that pressure builds up
because of massive losses in the
military there's a backlash to get from
soldiers mothers and their families that
you know people around start to put
blame where it's due which is on putin
and the tiny coterie of people who've
made this decision and say look we've
got to stop this but we can't
necessarily stop it with him there if
you were advising uh president biden now
what would you advise him to do in terms
of the short term into the medium term
well the short term we've got on the
medium term on the long term we've got
to stay unified as the west pushing back
we've also got to
extend the diplomatic front because one
of the things that we're really worried
about is putin and the nuclear weapon i
mean you haven't asked that but it's
something that looms yeah always and
that's unacceptable what he's doing
threatening to you know basically if you
don't back off and give me ukraine i'm
gonna blow you all up or i'm gonna you
know set off a demonstration tactical
nuclear weapon there we should be out
there with every other nuclear power the
uk of course is a nuclear power france
is a nuclear power china's nuclear power
butts or india and pakistan everywhere
else and say look what he's doing so
diplomacy on that front sticking
together to blunt the
russian military operation and being
dedicated and committed over the long
term over changes in presidents
political parties you know we have to
find mechanisms for this to help ukraine
get back on its feet but not stepping up
military intervention
those things are all part of this we've
all we're already in there um in terms
of all of the support that we've been
giving ukraine but we have to be careful
because putin wants it to be about the
us and the western nato he wants us to
kind of basically be in there because
he's telling the rest of the world
including india and everywhere else
where you've just been this is nothing
for you here this is nothing for you to
pay attention to this is just a fight
with us on the west and nato
and ukraine is collateral damage a lot
of countries and their leadership
believe that we have to push back
against that that's a short order
um goal for us to persuade the india's
indonesia's malaysia's you know and
others um and um asia
africa and elsewhere that look what's
happening to ukraine is something you
should all be concerned about as well
and fiona they keep telling me i've got
stocks i've run over yeah
i i could go on and on believe it it's
fascinating
as a child you said you were scared of
nuclear war and here we are again a
major nuclear power openly threatening
using those weapons are you scared
actually not in the way that i was when
i was a kid i was scared of the unknown
because i didn't know how this was all
play out i mean now i've got some pretty
good ideas of how this all plays out and
the whole point of this is we shouldn't
be scared and intimidated
for putin right now this is a game even
though it's a pretty dangerous one
nonetheless because he's scared he's
scared of being usurped he's scared that
he doesn't have sufficient conventional
power he's scared that we could indeed
push him back he's scared that ukraine
could win so this is basically the act
of a scared person himself he doesn't
say he is because he has to portray this
strength and power but he's falling back
on his new nuclear weapon systems we
have to understand
where he's coming from and we have to
push back against that so the whole
secret of this is don't be scared and
intimidated but take some action
one more question they'll tell me off
if you could you say to me confidently
though here now that you don't think he
would use a nuclear weapon or you simply
don't know i don't know and i think he's
thinking about how we could use it you
know as a demonstration in fact in a way
he's already used it because he's
talking about it and we saw what he did
in chernobyl in terms of sending the
military right through the chernobyl
exclusion zone shelling the zaparian
nuclear plant he's already in that space
and you know threatening you know moving
nukes here and there and using iskandar
missiles and talking about it that we
know can be you know basically
nuclear-armed he's already in that space
so we have to push back we have to work
with others this is the point where we
say to the rest of the world look you
really want to be in a world with a
nuclear free-for-all that's why we have
to put putin and his you know nuclear
missiles back in the strategic bottle
here you know he's basically unleashed
the nuclear genie we have to put that
back fiona hill thank you so much uh we
need to go thank you so much cameron now
because i've got loads of questions
thank you thanks for coming on thank you
it's great great to be here with you
both thank you for having me i loved it
thank you thank you